si nous et thomas sont de jeunes trentenaires
fiers de leur artisanat la coutellerie un travail
de précision où la matière prend forme sous leurs
doigts véritable créateur ils ont conçu et réalisé
un couteau originale qui s'inscrit dans leur
territoire tout simplement à taulé le chinon
le chinon c'est un coteau qui est assemblé
ici dans nos ateliers il est différenciée
par deux guillochage différents et nous allons
également 30 essences de bois différentes on
travaille également la corde sur le manche le
bois de cerf la corne de buffle essentiellement
fruit d'une année de recherches et de travail
le chinon est l'aboutissement d'un long parcours
commencé dans la restauration une reconversion
dans l'artisanat assez naturel pour les deux
compères qui ont su allier leurs compétences et
leur savoir faire je vais plutôt m'intéresser à
tous qui va cuisiner âge d'acier donc la suite
acheter l'âme le guillochage des manches sinon
lui est plutôt spécialisé dans le façonnage du
bois donc les plaquettes et la réalisation des
étuis en cuir également ce qui fait la qualité
de leur travail c'est l'attention qu'il porte en
matière et au geste précis un savoir faire unique
en touraine on s'imagine que les gens vont pouvoir
associer à chinon un couteau en plus quoi couteau
régionales c'est ce qu'on souhaite n'est vraiment
apporté à cette région aux territoires chinonais
un petit peu notre savoir-faire en coutellerie
et apporter à ce patrimoine encore une pièce
est un élément en plus du vin et tout un tas
de choses qui se font dans la région dès
le mois de janvier le chinon or à son tire
bouchon de quoi ravir les amateurs du chinon qui
ouvriront leurs bouteilles de vin avec un chinon